alan wake 2 has been confirmed as a
third person title halo infinite speed
runners are already breaking the game
and more
alan week 2 was announced at the game
awards and while it might be making a
change to its genre it won't be straying
from some of the core gameplay
fundamentals of the original remedy boss
sam lake confirmed on twitter that the
sequel will still be a third person game
amid questions about whether the sequel
might make a change akin to resident
evil 7 and village in their first person
perspective alan wake 2 will however
skew more towards traditional survival
horror a twist on the original's more
psychological horror focus additionally
the sequel will see the return of the
two people who brought the character of
alan wake to life matthew peretto will
return as the voice of the author
protagonist who you might recognize as
dr casper darling in remedy's most
recent game control ika villi will
return as the live-action actor and
model for alan wake already having
appeared in the game's first trailer
alan wake 2 is set to launch in 2023 on
xbox series xns ps5 and pc with epic
games helping fund the development
the halo community is having a field day
with the freedom halo infinite's open
world campaign provides and it didn't
take players long to figure out how to
skip many of the game's story missions
entirely halo content creator mint blitz
shows how one such trick is done in a
new video in which he credits the
discovery of the skip to members of the
halo runs speed running community what's
notable about the skip is that it
doesn't seem all that difficult to
accomplish as long as you know how just
about anyone can probably pull this off
this skip involves upgrading the grapple
shot to the fourth level to acquire the
first strike ability which allows
players to perform a powerful melee in
conjunction with grappling once players
reach the excavation site mission
players should end the game and reload
ensuring a new checkpoint in case the
glitch doesn't go as planned from there
players need to perform a grapple melee
in a very specific location near the
banish mining laser before immediately
bringing up the game's map and fast
traveling to any location this
apparently makes the players invincible
with the game believing the players to
actually already be dead in this state
timed death barriers are disabled
allowing players to go from one gap
using the grapple shot melee before
immediately grappling again to fling
themselves onto the island proper from
there it's just a matter of acquiring a
banshee and flying to the game's second
to last mission loading the mission will
remove the invulnerability glitch and
allow players to play the game normally
mint blitz doesn't think this glitch
will be patched as halo campaigns have a
long history of game breaking glitches
that developers have left untouched
hence why he felt comfortable sharing
the skip there's a link to mint blitz's
full video in the description below
as we close out the year game pass has
announced the new december lineup of
games that are heading to the platform
on cloud console and pc game pass
members will be able to play mortal
kombat 11
the gunk broken age and more starting
december 16th already out this month is
sirius sam4 and one of my personal
favorites to relax to townscaper there
are also some dlc and game updates from
ark survival evolved minecraft dungeons
and the elder scrolls online available
now too but of course when we get new
games on game pass that means we have to
say goodbye to a few others you'll have
until december 31st to play pro
evolution soccer 2021 the little acre
yakuza 0 yakuza kiwami 1 and 2. for the
full list of games be sure to check out
gamespot.com
there's definitely no shortage of games
to check out during the holidays so
which ones are you looking to try for
the first time let me know in the
comments and be sure to leave a like and
subscribe so you don't miss your next
gamespot news update
[Music]
you